última jornada de un extenso proceso el
más largo de la historia judicial
francesa como es requerido en un proceso
penal los 14 acusados toman la palabra y
sal a abdeslam es el último en hablar
aborda ampliamente sus condiciones de
detención y arremete contra la acusación
asegura que él no es un asesino es con
la espada de la fiscalía sobre la cabeza
que me dirijo a ustedes no soy un
asesino y si me condenan por asesinato
estarán cometiendo una injusticia la
mayoría de los acusados asegura haber
cambiado a lo largo de la audiencia
frente a los testimonios de las víctimas
no he esperado para tener remordimientos
todos los días tenemos remordimientos es
muy duro ver a las víctimas sentadas en
la sala a la salida de la audiencia
algunas víctimas se declaran satisfechas
de estas últimas palabras de los
acusados
los testimonios aportados al estrado por
la parte civil han tenido realmente un
impacto ha habido sinceridad emoción
para todos
fuck tus hay que olvidar que detrás de
los crímenes que cometieron que ayudaron
a cometer continúan siendo hombres que
han hecho cosas horribles pero son
hombres así que imagino que les ha
afectado la acusación pide condenas que
van desde los cinco años de prisión
hasta la cadena perpetua irreducible
para sal a abdeslam la última audiencia
de este lunes fue esencial para la
defensa tras más de nueve meses de
juicio porque se demostró ya es
necesario que sus palabras sean eficaces
sobre todo no retomamos elementos del
proceso judicial no es un alegato sólo
es una última impresión el momento de
hablar evidentemente de las víctimas es
importante ver qué consecuencias han
tenido nueve o diez meses de audiencia
sobre la conciencia de los individuos
los magistrados del tribunal se han
retirado para deliberar en un cuartel
militar en la región parisina tienen que
examinar los cargos que pesan sobre los
acusados uno por uno el veredicto se
espera este miércoles al final de la
tarde hora de parís
[Música]